Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Monday
morning podcast for Monday. He over there.
It's uh,
June 22nd,
2015 and I am in Santa Rosa.
Santa Rosa with it makes the one
you're naughty say, um, California,
Santa Rosa. And um,
last night I performed,
I don't even know. I can't remember the
name of the venue. The Wells Fargo. Oh,
Ho the wells Fargo wagon is,
uh,
I can't even look it up on my
website because my fucking website,
the second I do the Gig, he's
like, go fuck yourself. It's over.
That information no longer exists.
Wait a second, we look me up here.
Let me look me up. Oh God.
He's in his ego this week.
Basically I would gives a fuck
with the name of the thing was, um,
the venue I played last
night was the, uh, the venue.
George Carlin did his
last stand up special.
And um, someone, I thought,
someone told me that this was the
place where he did his last show.
I was the wells Fargo
Center for the, Ah, um,
this is the place where he did,
um,
his recorded his last special and his
last performance was at the Orleans Casino
in Las Vegas. If you're a
George Carlin, not like me. Um,
so last night I was, I was standing
backstage and I don't, man,
it was really fucking cool.
It was such an amazing venue.
It had like the lower level.
And then I had like this,
this small upper deck that
just wrapped around, you know,
all three sites that I
was looking out at it.
It looked like a minor league ballpark.
And the crowd was,
I could tell when Bart Nick
went out there, they were, uh,
they were just a really smart crowd and
a one of my best shows of the fucking
tool. So I really want to thank everyone
that came out last night and um,
you know, it was a good
time. I Dunno, who knows.
I ended up staying on the up to like
four in the morning with fucking Barnick
much in full metal jacket and
drinking this wine because you know,
we're in wine country,
so they just given us this fucking wine
and we're drinking it and I have the
worst goddamn hangover. I
fucking, I appreciate wine.
But wine should only be drank with
like a good meal. You know what I mean?
Seminar women can drink it. I don't
know how the fuck they do it. You know,
around four,
four 30 when they really just can't
deal with their fucking kids anymore.
They just, you know, they
pop in a DVD, you know? Okay,
go watch spongebob takes over fucking
Japan, whatever the fuck they're doin.
Right.
Spongebob First Pokemon come on kids,
you know,
this was just sit out and then they
just fucking did just start boozing,
which I totally respect.
I don't know how the fuck they do
with them and it's a brutal hangover.
So I'm like, all right, the bus isn't,
we're not leaving until 11 in the morning,
you know. So I stayed up till like four
in the morning and the back of my head,
it's like, well, I gotta do
my podcasts. It's like, Eh,
no big deal I'll do on the bus and
I'll just fucking uploaded. And uh,
it like fucking eight 30 in the morning.
The people staying in the room next to me,
they had these two little kids,
like real young. Those fucking
kids are up at the crack of dawn.
And one of them was,
you know,
there's a door between my hotel room and
the other one and one of them with his
little baby hand was just
slapping the door, you know,
talking Jibo's. Yeah. I can't, I
can't just slap, slap, slap bitch.
Kiki can't get mad at a
baby. You know what I mean? I
mean, I guess some people do,
you know, that doesn't usually end up
well. I think babies are pretty much, uh,
they've yet to win in a fight with
an adult. You know what I mean?
They like the 1977 fucking Tampa Bay
Buccaneers that just went all and 14.
You know,
I don't know what it is with babies.
They really got to turn it around
when they're fighting adults,
they got her somehow they've
got to change the culture,
you know,
then that nursery in somehow try to get
out there and try and find a way to win.
You know? Cause I'll tell
you right now, you know,
if they keep doing what
they're doing or you know,
they're never going to beat an
adult. You liked that? I wanted to,
I went to Mike Golick there.
Yeah, the kid cry. So um,
it's unfucking real, just that
kids just fucking wake up and they,
they don't even have to stretch.
You know what I mean?
Like the four I get out of bed,
I swear to God,
if I just lay down and watch TV for
20 minutes, if I get out of bed,
I feel like I haven't walked in nine
years. Like I, before I get out of bed,
I literally have to take my fucking toes
and point them at my knees and hold it
there for like, fuck, it
felt like a good 30 seconds.
Then I get up, I'm fine if I don't do
that. If I just get up and start walking,
I do that,
you know,
you take that one and a half steps and
you do that little fucking quick little
of like somebody just kicked you in the
side of the leg, you go, oh, you know,
and I have to stop putting my hands down
on the mattress and then stretch out my
fucking whatever it is. My Achilles,
just kids just get up and run,
man. You know, I swear to God, if I,
is it illegal, they get
your baby drunk, you know,
just social sleep longer and when it wakes
up it's just going to lay there like,
ah shit. Yeah. Uh, fuck it.
Let me just lay here. Let me just lay
here for another 20 minutes, you know?
So what I would do if I had a baby,
I would just get it hammered big time,
drink up. You know, I put a right,
this formula, is that illegal?
You know,
I know you,
you're not allowed to drink publicly
until you're 18 but if you're with your
parent or legal guardian,
catch you get fucked up together.
I'm seriously asking you that. You
know, what if it's wine, you know,
you make it sophisticated,
like whatever, like,
like if you have like one of those
Gerber ones, if it's a lighter color,
do you go with the white wine for the
baby and then if it's like one of those
ones that has beets in it,
you get them a red or is that redundant?
Is that vulgar to have,
uh,
that two colors on top of each other?
I have no idea. I have no idea.
I'm not sophisticated. Like, like
you fucking wine drinkers, you know,
somebody has got gotta be, do I know the,
obviously I know that's fucking illegal,
but somebody out there's got to be
doing it, you know, like Jesus Christ.
It's like if you're a night owl and your
kid just wakes up at six in the morning,
something has to give,
you know,
then they used to do that
when babies were teething,
they pour a little booze into
their milk or something like that.
Or did they rub it right on their
gums? You know, like the kids,
some fucking cop
trying to determine whether
it's cocaine or not. You know,
they always do that in the fucking
TV shows and the movies where like,
they're like, what do you got
there Mike? And he goes, you know,
he does a little little tap, tap,
tap, and a Christian. He said, yeah,
this is the real deal.
You know? Oh, he's crying,
poor thing. Whenever you hear
a baby cry, just start fucking,
I'd always makes me laugh. I always
just think like, you know what dude,
I hear you.
I want to do that too.
I wish I could still cry like that the
way baby does. Just over little things.
I think I wouldn't be angry
anymore. He says, you just
get it out of you. You know,
if I go to turn on my phone and I find
out that I didn't recharge it the night
before and it's completely dead,
you know,
rather than the fucking Goddamn fucking
idiot bill. What if I just went,
he just fucking cry it out.
Oh my God.
How much would your wife fucking freak
out if he just started doing that?
I wish I could do it for real,
you know,
just as a joke with me and just tell her
that I fucking w I'm reading this new
book on crying it out and just
see how long it could sustain it.
Yeah.
I didn't think I could cry once. She
just be like, put the fuck are you doing?
You know what I mean?
And then I would just cry.
Like you don't have a baby
does when you yell at it.
Okay.
I Dunno what it is.
Maybe he's just fucking make me
laugh no matter what they're doing.
Like if me see those psychos,
like when you're on a fucking plane,
I think I feel like I just keep going.
Like, what if this happened? Like,
did you ever have this happen? Like
why am I talking, I gotta do it again.
Instead of saying like,
why am I talking as if I'm a seventh
grade girl chewing gum. You know why?
Cause I went to bed at like
four 30 in the morning.
That's why she going to
have to deal with it. Oh,
Billy teeny bopper hears this week.
Um,
whenever I'm on a fucking
plane and a baby starts crying,
whenever I see people like the,
those people get angry
and they put on their fucking
Bose noise canceling. Thanks.
You know,
I always feel like anybody who has the
money to buy headphones that all they do
is just block out the sound of
other people. It's just like
there's only the only way
you could do that as a few.
Uh, he had like blood money.
Who's got the money for Bose?
Fucking,
they're like $300 and only do is
just block out people talking.
It actually sounds great. If I hit a
fucking pair of those on right now,
then I wouldn't hear those kids crying. I
don't know what it is. No idea. Anyways,
so what I'm trying to say is
happy father's day, everybody
happy belated father's Day.
You know,
did you get your dad a man?
Great. So he knows that you care.
You know, man, fucking hilarious.
They just advertise once a year.
Like your dad only wants steak house
quality once a fucking once a year.
That's it. You know, I called up, uh,
a bunch of my friends who are dads
and I was just like, hey, you know,
happy father's Day. What are you doing
today? And they'll be that guy, you know,
mom working in the yard.
Oh, you know, again, uh,
putting up a shelf for some, I'm like, no,
what are you doing, you know, for your,
your sort of birthday here is,
it's father's Day in every one of them.
Just,
it was just one shitty thing
after another. It's like,
now you guys are going out
to like a teddy bar. None.
He had gone to a ball game
just out in the fucking yard.
I don't know what the, I
don't get that. You know,
Mother's Day don't you take her
out for a little eggs benedict.
You get us of flowers.
I feel bad for the dads out there.
What could you do? You know, even
if there's a steak, I mean, God,
God knows you got to go
out and go make it right.
Unless you Paul Versey puffers. He
doesn't fuck with his grill. Sound real.
I went over his house one time,
you know,
we were having burgers and he didn't
even make them. They can't have that man.
You can't have somebody else,
man. And you're fucking grill.
Okay.
I mean, what happens next? You know,
you let a man come over your house and
he cooks on your grill and you're not
cooking on it.
I mean,
within five minutes he's going to be
slow dancing with your wife. He can't,
I don't even,
I don't even care if you suck at it. I
mean, it's not that hard. Get good at it.
Right. Just make a couple
of Burgers, some hotdogs.
Jesus Christ version. Um, you know, it's
funny as later on today we'll be like,
ah, dude. Did you see it in
cocoa? My, I don't I fucking
cock domain. No, you didn't.
You didn't. Um, anyway, so this
is the Monday morning podcast is,
we're working our way through
June, um, me and Barton and Bart.
Nick is absolutely fucking destroying
in front of me. Man. It's great.
It's making me have better sets
because a student is bringing the heat,
he's bringing the fire.
Um,
he's just one of my favorite comics. I'm
going to leave it. That fucking guy, just,
he's, it's, his act is just so blunt.
And even when he talks, he
just gets right to it. And, uh,
I can't even say half to shit. He says,
cause it's so fucking politically correct.
But he talked to me about,
I forget what he's worked in some places,
some biker came in with all his biker
buddies and in one of them peeled off from
wanting to go into this room and Joe
was like, yeah, you can't go in here.
And the guy was like, oh, I
can't go in there. And Joe just,
Joe has a way of like, uh, you know,
just having a look on his face where all
the emotion goes away and it makes you
fucking blood run cold.
So he's telling the story and he
goes to the bike and goes, oh,
I can't go in there. And then Joe
just makes that face and goes, no,
you can't go in there.
And he said,
him and the biker guy was staring at
each other and then the biker dude back
down. And he was just like,
all I was thinking was, uh,
you know,
hey dude,
I can go back to Pittsburgh and make
pizzas while you pussy biker friends of
putting you in the ground.
I left out a couple of words of,
Oh my God, he said that shit and I
think I came in with a fuck we wore.
It was me and somebody else just,
we'll fucking crying,
laughing and Joe sitting
there still deadpan like what?
Like he went into that mindset. I don't
think I've ever thought I had thought.
I don't, I don't remember a
time anybody threatened my life,
but if they had that look
on their face that Joe had,
there's no fucking way I wouldn't. I
went back down to, I'd be, I go, okay.
He later walked in with my biker jacket
over my forearm. Like a gentleman,
you know, Jesus Christ. People got
tattoos in northern California.
My God, I saw this woman,
she was so tatted up.
It went all the way up
her neck and then like,
you know when they go beyond the neck
but not quite there face, what do,
what does that party if you face
between your neck and your chin?
It's like the Tanti your
face, you know? Is that all,
I mean I get Chin is that thing
right in the front, right?
Jesus Christ bill taken an anatomy
class. Oh fuck you. What is it?
What is the underneath?
Is that still part of the neck
or is that part of the chin?
What would you say that you put the
gun right under his fucking chin. Yeah,
I guess that's be Your Chin, right?
I don't fucking know. Anyways,
she was tatted right up to where if
he had a cleft chin, it stopped there.
And right along her face too.
You know,
like when somebody has a
really neatly trimmed beard,
it literally looked like she
was slowly drowning and tattoos.
Like if you stared at her long enough
it was going to move up another inch and
she was going to start panicking,
worrying if she was still going
to be able to breathe. Um,
do you know,
don't really is normal now is actually
to have a tattoo on your face.
It's not as shocking.
The only time we used to see it was
back in the day when you watch national
geographic and there's some
tribe down in South America,
they just draw all over each other's face,
you know,
worse than like prison tattoos. It
looks like Morse Code, you know,
or like a what are those things you
had before there was the internet.
He had crossword puzzles and mazes get
through the maze and you drew like a
pencil on it so they'd just like the
drum maze on their fucking face. Um,
I just saw a lot like chicks with just
fucking giant pieces. I believe them.
They call them all up and
down their, their, their arms.
It's like everybody out here plays in
good Charlotte or something. I don't,
I don't understand it. They're great
people. Good looking people too.
Good looking broads up here in northern
California. I got to get you this a,
I know I'm all over the place. I don't
give a fuck. I got to get you this,
this picture of this guy,
um,
who had a tattoo of his baby's
face put on the side of his face.
Yeah.
And like part of it like went in, covered
up part of his ear, like where the,
and then it was also really dark. I
didn't get it. I mean it was a white baby.
It's like why is this thing so dark?
It was like, it looked like a baby.
That was like, if it was
me as a baby, but for some,
I dunno, kids stuck his head in the
fireplace. It's like just the worst.
So where's fucking tattoo I've ever seen
in my life and this guys go and check
it out, man. Check out my new ink.
Mainly we look at this man puts tattoo
sewn on Facebook. I love,
I love Facebook man.
That's when you know you're old. When
you like Facebook and all the kids look,
Ooh, fucking Facebook. So
lame. Good. Get out of here.
You fucking punk and want you around here.
Anyways,
the dumb stories thinking you're
lived life. You haven't. All right,
you fucking dope.
I'm actually that old now.
When I look at people in their 20s like
college age kids and I just think I have
what a bunch of fucking dopes
when they drink the way they behave.
I used to think I was a maniac dude. I'm
fucking crazy. It's like, no I wasn't.
I was some nerd who couldn't handle the,
the freedom of not being
around his parents anymore
as experiencing that for the
first time.
Oh,
I'm going to get drunk and jump off
something so that chick over there thinks
I'm funny or crazy and then maybe
she'll blow me like really bill,
that was she game plan.
All right man.
Puts Tattoo a baby's face on his face.
Probably be like 20 different pictures
of some dummy doing this. There it is.
There it is. Yeah. And
he's holding his baby.
He's got a white baby, Eh, this, this
baby looks like, I dunno. It's weird.
It looks like the baby is a yeah.
Coming out of [inaudible]
fireplace, you know, face
maybe a little on fire.
What a fucking,
why would you do that?
Wait,
where could that guy get?
He couldn't even get a job in
a fucking nursery like glove.
Look how much I love babies, but none,
none. Not in a structural way. Jesus,
I just yelled at and they have babies
next door. Oh, they can't hear me?
Of course they can hear you bill.
Their kids aren't yelling that loud.
You can hear them right now. Jesus. Well,
this would be my evidence. Bright if they
came in. Why are you talking about? Uh,
I can't remember what
the fuck I just said. Oh,
not in a sexual way while you're talking
about babies in a sexual way. I be like,
no.
I actually did a podcast officer here
at listened to him and then he takes my
device and just a racist at
some crooked cop.
All right. I didn't know what the
fuck I'm talking about here. Um,
I wrote about 19 minutes and I think it's
time to listen to bill. Read out loud.
What do you guys think? Huh? What are you
all right.
Hey,
my batteries died so I had to go to
the front desk and go get some more
batteries.
That every level high.
That's what the record says because he
has the English lady in there because it
makes your device more
classy. So this, uh,
lady Butler that's in my recorder
kept going back every level medium.
So I'm thinking it's going
to, you know. All right,
well I don't have to worry about anything
until fucking Queen Elizabeth goes bat
every level low.
And then I was going to buy batteries,
but this shit went from battery
level high to battery level,
medium to just shutting off.
You know what I mean?
It's like when somebody, you know, just
gets divorced out of fucking nowhere.
And like, I thought they were getting
along, Craig. Not a nowhere. We just,
we decided to go our separate ways.
Did you?
Well, that's good. Good for
you. Good on you. All right.
So anyways, let's get to the,
uh, let's listen to me read out loud. Oh,
here we go. Hold me undies. Me undies.
I got to sing this quietly because
it's fucking kids next door.
[inaudible] undies put
'em on your fucking whore.
If you balls are wet they won't be
anymore cause you put on this shit dead a,
you're going out the door.
Your balls is swing in from left and
right but they feel real comfortable.
Oh yeah,
they even got him for your claim.
But booboo you don't me
undies is actually using that.
No more sweaty balls and people look,
are you getting money for that?
Of course I'm not.
Why would they pay me for that?
You know I'm singing like a,
you can get anything you
want at Alice's restaurant.
I should be getting fucking
sued by a Arlo Guthrie.
Whoever wrote that fucking
song. All right. 90% people.
That's the percent of your life
that you spend in your underwear.
Unless you're Matthew mcconaughey and
then it's like 2% I don't think he has his
underwear and his ball sweaty.
Who knows?
He's got that goofy look on his
face. Maybe they are. I don't know.
I don't pretend to know about his scrotum.
I only know is,
I bet they're tanned up real nice.
Oh Shit.
I bet.
Do you think anybody's putting any botox
and then ball bag yet to make it nice
and smooth anyways,
underwear, it gets old fast.
You know that feeling of
putting on old saggy underwear,
you need to know the feeling of putting
on Greg fitting underwear that's two
times softer than cotton.
I'm still waiting from the
rebuttal from the cotton people.
You need to know about me undies Dotcom,
me,
Andy says the most comfortable underwear
you will ever try on and it's insane
how good they make your balls feel.
They fit perfectly. Just Cup them.
They don't ride up on you
and they literally pull
moisture rows away from your
skin. See a steak? Cool.
I don't understand that.
The purpose of sweating
is to cool down your body.
How about you don't feel bad
because you don't have swamp ass.
I guess that's a little grocer. All right,
so you stay cool. We'll go with that.
But you know something.
They also make you look great.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and check
out the photography and for the ladies,
checkout those smoking hot boy shorts,
but you have to try them on for yourself.
This quality would typically read. Yeah,
to see how they look on your ass
as opposed to the models. Right?
Everybody has to do that.
You know what I mean?
It's like the guys Calvin
Klein underwear where they,
the dude on the package has
the abs and then you put it on,
you get your fucking man muffin
top going on and you're like, well,
I thought it was going to
look like Mark Walberg there.
And instead I look like if
I drive a garbage truck, um,
this quality would typically retail
for two times to me, undies, price,
no retail middleman means
more savings to you.
Here we will make it easy.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash and get
20% off your first order and low flat
rate. International shipping save even
more. When you buy a pack of them,
they guarantee you're going to be happy
with them or your first pair is free.
Once you feel me undies up against your
balls, you never going back and me,
Andy's isn't just for guys. If he didn't
fucking listen to two paragraphs ago,
they just launched their, all
of me. Why not take all of me.
There's that clam and it's dry and
cool.
Go down on her.
It's like eaten those fucking meant
that you get only at the movies.
All of me women's collection, I couldn't
remember. I kept thinking juicy fruit.
What the fuck is the name of those mints?
You know you have like
three of them are like,
these are delicious and then you
have seven. You're like, oh my God,
I want to kill myself.
Junior mints, right?
A four piece line of undies designed
specifically for the female body and all
its complex. Gorgeous has held glories
but get that, but to get that 20% off,
you have to go to [inaudible] dot com
slash [inaudible] that's [inaudible] dot
com slash per. Hey, I bought a fucking
standing ovation for me undies.
Not Having to say it three times. All
right, dollar shave club. Everybody.
Some of you out there still haven't joined
dollar Shave Club like that screaming
baby, but that baby doesn't need to shave,
but you do. So what is your problem?
These guys are awesome. These
dollar shave club people. Seriously,
I've been a fan for years. Evidently,
and you've heard me talk about them.
Their razors are amazing and it's more
convenient and costs a fraction of the
price. Still not getting it. You
dumb. Fuck. Here's how the club works.
Go to dollar shave club.com and pick
one of their three great razors.
The six blade executive for you.
Half a Werewolf's out there.
That's for somebody with back hair.
They got to shave like just during
the day as they're talking to you.
They just keep shaving a the four blade
for x and the two blade humbled twin.
You're a,
you get your first box in about a week
and includes a free handle and a sleeve
of blade cartridges. It's high
quality stuff. Got that weight to it,
if you know what I'm saying. Like the
expensive ones you've used before.
The humble twin has to stainless
steel blades and an aloe strip.
That's all you need. You've never gotten
a shave like this after that first box.
They mail you a sleeve of replacement
blades every month or every other,
however you want to do it and you never
have to worry about it again. That's it.
If you haven't joined yet,
you're missing out and you're wasting
party of life standing in line down there
at the fucking cvs over
there. Simple as that. Drive.
Dollar Shave club.com/burr that's dollar
shave club.com/burr and they only did
too. It's like people are
listening to me. All right,
let's read the last one here.
stamps.com everyone,
most of us are trying to find more time
everyday to get things done so you can
let trips to the post
office slow you down.
I'll see you can't let trips
to the post office slowly now.
Now you don't have to.
Thanks to stamps.com that makes no sense,
so you can't let trips to the post
office slow down. Now you don't have to.
Oh yeah, it does. It makes
sense. When I tried three times,
thanks to stamps.com with stamps.com you
can buy and print official us postage
right from your own computer or printer
stamps.com we'll even send you a digital
scale that automatically calculates the
exact postage you need for any letter or
package.
Any class of male.
You'll never waste valuable time
going to the post office again.
Do it right now from your desk with
stamps.com print the postage you need,
put it on your letter or package.
Then just hand it to your
mail carrier and you're done.
I use stamps.com to send out all my
posters that I sell at the end of my shows
when I want to whore myself out. Right
now. Use My last name, birth, B, U R,
R for this special no risk trial plus
$110 bonus offer that includes a digital
scale it up to $55 free postage.
Don't do not wait. Everybody,
go to stamps.com before
you do anything else,
click
on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbirththatstamps.com
enter
burr. Oh, actually there is one more.
Well, we'll get to that one later.
We'll get to that one
later. Um, all right.
What else did I want to talk
about this week? I, by the way,
that fucking horrible tragedy,
that Douche shooting up the, uh,
the church.
Can Somebody please explain to me?
I don't understand this as a white person.
Why are white people trying to
act like that wasn't a racist act.
Okay.
I mean, did he have to have, I'm a racist,
tattooed across his fucking forehead.
What else? Why? Why? I just,
I hate when people fucking,
they look at their race like it's a team.
You know what I mean?
It's like me when I defend Tom
Brady and you guys all go out.
If it was on the other fucking way,
they know Andrew luck did it.
You'll be shitting on him. Right?
I'd like to think I wouldn't be,
but people do that with like race.
So because like they say in this racist
White Dude is racist and somehow they
say in your racist and not saying you're
racist, you fucking moron. He's a racist.
And why people stop fucking acting like
you don't know racist white people.
Okay.
You know that guy at the cookout who
out of gets a couple of beers in him and
starts dropping the n word and then you've
got to be, hey, hey, take it easy clock.
Come on. I try to have a good time
here. Right, that fucking guy.
And then hopefully you
don't ever invite him again.
Why are you acting like those
fucking people don't exist?
You know that that guy's a
racist at your fucking cookout.
And all he did was dropped again,
word while he was eating a cheeseburger.
This fucking guy went into that church
specifically to kill black people cause
he hated black people. I mean,
what, what the fuck mortar you need?
There was like nine shows. If I had any
hair left that would have tore it out.
Watching them going, what the fuck
are you trying to defend? Sorry.
None of that was funny, but it
was fucking true. Um, anyways,
getting back to the podcast here,
I saw this article on, uh, uh,
Jesus. Then I get rid of it. Where is
it? There it is. This fucking guy who it,
who was evidently the 970th
member of guns and roses.
And I know, even though I'm making
fun of that fucking band, you know,
I don't even make in front of the
band like the musicians think.
It's just the fact that they're still
calling it guns and roses. Right.
That would be like if you
bought Mcdonald's and you fired,
you fired that fucking clown
and you're still going. Yeah.
And you fired the grimace
and the hamburglar and you
got rid mayor mccheese none
of them were there anymore. But like, uh,
I dunno the fucking one of them. One of
the grimace stuck around. No you don't.
Ronald McDonald did. Cause
Axel is a fucking red hat. Um,
and you, you still acting like it's this
band of brothers, whatever. So anyways,
is this article by um,
the 9000th guitarist and guitarist,
the guy's Dj ash ba and it says DJ,
but guns and roses guitarist,
Dj ash ba claims his aunt and uncle
invented technology for aerosol cans.
All right. Uh, guns and
roses and 6:00 AM Nikki Sixx,
his band guitarist.
Dj Asheville was interviewed by
Sweetwater editorial director,
Mitch Gallagher. Duh Duh Duh Duh, Duh.
Here's what he said. Ashleigh says,
who owns a company centered around media
and advertising that runs various other
countries, was asked, what
takes him in those directions?
He responds now basically they
wrote exactly what he said,
so I'm gonna maybe fuck up the emotion
of this thing. But basically he said,
you know, I don't know. I've
always had that creative bone.
My aunt and uncle invented the
technology for aerosol cans.
So ever since I was young. Dot. Dot. Dot.
They came out with a product when
I was really young called Pam.
That's like a buttery spray.
And I've always kind of
grew up in that environment.
I thought outside the box,
and it really taught me that it's better
to create your own job then to work
nine to five. So that's what's always
been my mindset. I just love creating.
Ashleigh also talked about his belief
that musicians should diversify and have a
backup plan.
He said,
I absolutely will always stand by that
if you put all your eggs in one baskets,
all you got to do is drop them and they're
going to break and every one of them
will break. But the whole
thing. Dot, dot. Dot.
And I've learned this from
6:00 AM band mate, Nikki Sixx.
It's like you set up buckets is set up
buckets, little incomes coming in there,
there, there, there, there.
And as a whole, that's how
you interact with this one.
Jesus Christ.
This is getting difficult.
If three buckets aren't
doing well this month,
but the other ones are you going
to be fine. So it's diversifying.
But if you put all your eggs in one bucket
and you have five months of, you know,
things aren't going that well that
could spill all your eggs right now.
What the fucking guy said in there,
I'm telling you,
is the key to freedom and making
your money work for yourself.
So I'm looking at the comments and
everybody's just shitting on him.
Next thing you know, he'll be telling
us he invented whippets so many roads.
So the fuck what I guess said some
new cool way of saying what the fuck.
And somebody wrote any invented
huffing aerosol cans. Uh,
I would like to salute
auntie and uncle ash,
but for making it possible for me to get
high on the cheap during my turbulent
and troublesome teen years,
uh,
by a real shirt.
So his aunt and uncle are responsible
for the deaths of countless insects for
screwing up the ozone layer.
And even worse for all the horrible
hairstyles of the eighties. Congrats.
Someone writes, this guy is
the ultimate poser. It's it.
Everybody just shits all over them.
Now,
I don't think he'd really fucking meant
era. So I think he just invented Pam.
I don't know what,
but in the middle of all that,
he said some brilliant shit about,
hey,
this guy's made it as a guitarist.
Right?
But then he started these business on
the side with the money that he's made.
So if the next album doesn't do well,
his business is doing well.
And this is thing. And, and you
know, I've found being a comedian,
people always say that, hey, you know,
if you have a fucking backup plan,
you're not going to go 100% as a comedian.
And I kind of bought into that Af,
you know,
early on.
But the reality is is you can
make all this money as a comedian,
as a guitarist is whatever you're doing.
But then you can take that money
and start other shit. You know,
I got this stupid ass podcast,
I got some money coming in from the
fucking advertising, I do my standup,
I got money coming in from that and now
I'm, I'm looking at, okay, maybe I'll,
I'll take this money and go
buy an apartment building
and become a fucking slum
Lord. And then when I'm in like 70 if
I own enough of those fucking things,
I don't have to go on the road.
Or if people are just like, oh,
he's fed old freckled fuck, he's been
talking about the same shit for 50 years,
fuck him. And I go back down
to plain in front of 30 people.
I can still do it because I love it,
but I won't become destitute.
And this guy is like giving you this
information for fucking free and everybody
just shits all over.
I don't know.
I found it really a really inspiring
and I'm a combination of that.
And I also, um, I was reading this thing,
I'm going to fuck up the guy's name.
I think his name is Nick Offerman.
That guy from that show.
Um,
you know where every parks and recs,
the guy looks like an older, uh,
Zach Galifianakis. You know, and
he's funny. He's fucking hell.
He does a lot of voiceover cartoon shit.
Why don't you just look it up built?
Cause you know what?
I got my fucking hands full right now.
I'm holding the recorder
and I got my phone,
but he had this great article and I'm
going to read this to you guys here.
It said, what, what is the best
advice you ever received? And he said,
I had this amazing teacher in college,
my Sensei in the Kabuki theater.
And I thought that that was
one of the women, you know,
fucking put on the makeup.
Right? And they gave you a hand job in the
end. I have no fucking idea. Anyways, um,
name shows. Oh Satco it probably
fucked up his name for me.
He was between Misdemeanor
Oggie and Obi wan Kenobi.
He told me to always maintain
the attitude of a student.
No matter how old you are, wake
up in the morning and think, okay,
how am I going to better myself?
Am I going to improve my French?
Am I going to get my wife a good back rub?
Then you can go to bed
having tried something.
It's led to a life that is more fruitful
than if you have the mindset of being a
master.
Once you think you're the master,
then you grow bitter waiting for someone
to throw you a parade because she's so
fucking smart. He didn't say fucking
smart, but those two things right there,
right there. You know what I mean? I
hope you got something out of that.
I have no fucking idea. But um,
that's the way he should go.
But if you play guitar, whatever the
fuck you do, you think that, yeah, dude,
I'm the shit. Then you stop growing and
then these young bucks run you down.
I'm basically saying people that even
though I can tell a shit joke at the level
that I can, I never stopped trying to
find a better way to tell that shit joke.
What if I squatted down and really
tried to take a shit on stage? I mean,
those are the kinds of things
I'm making fun of it,
but I really got inspired by both
of those things. So they got not,
I can't always be sitting here on the
podcast screaming. [inaudible] Kenny.
All right, let's add, let's do some adding
here. I did 19 minutes and 17, 19 and 17.
His fucking 38 minutes. I already
got another 22. Here we go. Um,
all right. What the fuck was I
did I want to talk about here? Oh,
so we went to Reno,
the biggest little town in America,
and uh, that was one of the rowdiest
fucking crowds I performed in front of,
in a long time.
And it kind of surprised me because
the last time I came to reno,
they weren't like that. But what
happened was, is we pulled in to Reno,
which I fucking love that city,
right? We pulled in and we just,
I'll see all these people in the street.
They had closed off the street.
We had to try to figure out how
to get the bus around. And uh,
they had this festival out there.
It was Bruce Blues and BBQ.
They should've said BBQs,
you know,
like you're getting more than
one barbecue just so it rhymes.
Bruce Blues and Bbq spot. It
was bloop bruise, blues and Bbq.
And I swear to God,
this shit show that was
walking around out in the sun,
the tattooed fucking shit show of
people walking around hammered,
you know,
parents who let their fucking inlaws
watched the kids and they're down.
They're sunburned.
Busan eaten barbecue.
Me and bargaining comedian would
just like, oh, this barbecue.
We got to fucking go. And we go down
there and people were fucking shit faced.
Well on their way to getting shit faced.
I saw some lady in the sun,
right sitting at this table with
their head down, like, you know,
you know when he came in from outdoor
recess and everybody was all amped up from
the sugar and salt,
you'd put in your bodies during lunch
and you came in and the teacher would be
like, all right, everybody put
your heads down on the desk.
Let's just take a little nap here.
Let's fucking relax so you're not bouncing
off the walls is I try to teach you
some phonics here. That's what she
looked like. And she was, I mean,
there was like two in the afternoon, so
me and Barnick or going like, all right,
let's get some barbecue.
Took us forever to find out where it was.
And then when we found it, if had
this ridiculously long line in Barton,
Mexican may gone do it. I don't
want to fucking stand in that line.
And I was like, yeah, fuck that. Let's not
stand. But then it seemed to be moving.
So we were like, fuck it. So
we stood in the line and, uh,
the barbecue was unbelievable.
One of the best briskets I ever had.
And I was sitting there going,
all right, I've been eating right.
I've been doing catio every day.
Um,
let's just pick one meat.
All right.
Either get the ribs to pull
pork or the fucking brisket.
And uh, you know, I was
starving. You know how that goes.
You Get up there and your
brain is telling you, you know,
just get the pulled pork, but just
get the ribs, you know, but the demon,
the sugar salt demon that's running
through your veins goes get all three.
And who do you give into you given
to the addiction? So I go, all right,
let me get,
let me get all three and some coleslaw
and one of those little fucking Jalapeno
cornbread. Thanks. So,
um, we fucking, you know,
I'm in front of Barnick,
I get all my shit and I get a lemonade
and I see this table with his two people
already sit in there, but there's an
umbrella in some shade. And you know,
I'm a redhead, so I'm one degree
away from a fucking albino.
So I beelined towards that
and I sit down. I said, Hey,
do you guys mind if we sit
here and this guy's like,
you know the cost you fucking eight
bucks. That's crazy. Fucking laugh.
And he's missing number eight.
Okay,
you got two teeth down front. Eight
nine going from right to left. Um,
he was missing number eight.
No, I'm sorry, number nine.
He was facing me. Sorry.
That's my dental office days. And
I didn't give a fuck. I was just,
I rolled with dead jokes,
you know, I was like, Oh man,
I'll give it to you in a check. He
goes, Nah, I'm kidding. I'm kidding.
It's only six bucks. [inaudible]
fucking crazy laugh missing a tooth.
And at that point Barton and
sits down and he's got that,
I'm going to murder a biker.
Look on his face.
And he just looks at me and he goes and
they're like trying to joke with him and
he completely ignores him and
he looks at me and he goes,
there's a tent over
there. And I go, Oh yeah.
And cause now it's all awkward cause he's
not interacting with these people who
are hammered telling the worst jokes ever.
And I'm pretending like they're funny.
And Joe goes, is a tent right
over there? And I just go, oh,
you want to go sit over there
instead? And he goes, yeah.
And he stands up and I like a little
kid, just go, okay guys, see Ya.
And walked over there. I started
laughing, I go, Jesus Christ. And he goes,
and he just goes by, Nick does this thing
where he just sort of puts his hand up,
one of his hands up. He goes, dude,
I want to enjoy my meal. Okay,
I don't want to sit there, talk to
her that, what did he call them?
Methy or something like that
with this missing tooth.
I just want to sit here and enjoy it.
And then we sat down at this other
fucking table and it was actually great.
We actually, where we sat there was
like a breeze and all this thing. Um,
and the fucking barbecue
is delicious. And, um,
I looked across the parking lot and
there was this little coffee shop,
little tiny coffee shop,
looked like there was enough room in
there for someone to stand and have a
coffee maker, little coffee shop
and you know, it was called,
it was called Pony Express.
So,
and my wife loves word place.
So immediately I took a picture
of it and I called her up,
you know,
and I been on the road for a little while
so she gets a little grumpy when I'm
gone that long.
Um,
which is funny cause when I get home then
she gets grumpy when I'm home for five
days. I'm a really annoying person.
So what I'm trying to tell you,
so I called her up and I told her
that joke and she fucking lost it.
I don't know why she loves wordplay,
but it's my,
one of my favorite things to do is when
I see some dumb word wordplay business
sign, I call her up. And every
once in a while something gets her.
And she likes horses.
If she thinks ponies acute.
And she just thought it
was the cutest name ever.
And she fucking laughs for like five
minutes making me laugh as I'm sitting at
devouring the barbecue. It might've been
the best moment of the tour. So anyways,
you'd think having done stand
up for 23 fucking years,
I would have done the math and
realized that this sunburn tattooed,
missing tooth shit show that was already
drinking four hours before my show was
going to start. Some of
them, some of those animals,
we're going to fucking come into the show.
It never dawned on me
and I went out on stage.
It was one of those things as a comic,
you come walking out on stage and you
just feel the vibe like, all right,
why do I feel like I'm in a saloon in
the 18 hundreds and I think I said one
thing and somebody yelled
from the to the left.
I don't know if that
stage left to stage right.
I never know how to fuck that works.
And just right out of the
gate it's like Jesus Christ.
I didn't even get a fucking word out.
So I wrote something about how they had
this person had horrible parents and
that's why this person was
behaving this way. And um,
and then that was basically the end
of the show. I had engaged with them.
So now it, it just became a
totally interactive experience.
It was actually a really fun show.
Um,
I do a couple of jokes and then I just
have to have a conversation with a drunk.
There was actually a guy in the crowd
who got kicked out and he wasn't with
anybody else.
He was by himself like he was,
he was basically the best drinker of
all of his friends is what I figured out
because somebody jets, I'm in the middle
of my joke and somebody just yell,
security,
security.
And they immediately made a beeline over
and I seen them grabbing this guy to,
you know, escorting them out.
And usually at that point,
this either at least one other person
with them screaming that it was bullshit
and there wasn't,
he walked out by himself and there
was just one empty chair and a,
I think that's when I finally put it
together and I was like, ah, okay,
now I get it.
You guys are the guys that I saw
drinking six hours ago out on the street.
And everybody laughed. It was one of those
crowds that would laugh at the jokes,
but they would really laugh when I would
snap and tell them how fucking drunk
and how much they're not paying attention,
then they would really laugh. Um,
but hopefully it was still a good show.
There was a few people that I was like,
oh, we should, could have so
in front of a sober crowd.
So I kind of felt bad about some
of that shit. But, um, I dunno,
it reminded me of my days when I was
working my way up as a comedian and I'm
just watching somebody go on in front
of you having to deal with the crowd,
but they weren't like Barton and click a
seasoned vet so they are able to handle
it like they were a new comic like I was.
And you would watch them going up just
person after person just bombing and
you'd be just thinking
like, oh my God. Oh my God.
Can you just try to come up with a
game plan? What am I going to do?
What joke am I going to open with?
What am I going to say to that guy?
That guy says anything to me.
Like back then I used to,
I used to have to plan out shit that I
was going to say rather than just go with
the frustration of the
moment in the moment. And um,
when you'd go up there, if
you bomb too, he just go home.
So fucking defeated in angry.
But if you actually won,
if he actually turned the room around,
it was just the greatest fucking feeling.
Like you felt like, uh, I dunno,
you felt like you when you were on
point of some platooned and somehow you
didn't get fucking whacked. I Dunno.
I Dunno what I'm talking about here.
So anyways,
um,
this is like big time wine
country out here and um,
we played bouncing back here.
I'll add bill here.
We played that theater last night and
it was just some of the greatest fucking
people backstage I've been with.
Like our bus driver ran into somebody
else that he knew back when he used to,
I guess I didn't know our bus driver
used to drive the Allman brothers and um,
I should have known he did because
he was fucking cool as shit.
And if you get a cool bus driver,
those guys work all the time.
We get some fucking Weirdo. You know
what I mean? They used to drive like,
you know, I dunno, Milli Vanilli
or some shit, right? So, um,
him and the other guy just sitting there
and we're hanging out and they had this
unbelievably gorgeous long dining room
table and it was one of those modern
rustic is what they call it was built
from wood, from an old ship and then,
and then the legs are,
were made out of metal and the
tables just indestructable.
What I loved about it is when
you have a table like that,
you can spill shit on it.
You could literally use it as a cutting
boy if you wanted to. And um, you know,
I should give you guys the
name of that fucking place. Um,
I guess they're expensive
is fucking hell. But, uh,
I've been looking for a dining room table
because we have this awful just round
one. We got it from our neighbors and
then we paid this guy to refinish it.
And uh, my wife, cause she's
so fucking creative, had these,
this design carved into it,
that was the same design of this
panel thing that was at our wedding.
She had not Jesus Christ.
I just realized there's no way she's
getting rid of that table. So. Well,
I guess I'm not buying a table
from these fucking people, but, uh,
if you guys would like a really great
fucking table coke is Decaux is it c o,
k a. S d. I k. O I believe
in there in Santa Rosa,
California. And um, they make tables
all different sizes. This was like,
what I loved about this table was
it was big enough that entire,
an entire band could come in and it was
a lot of music acts that played at this
venue could just come in and everybody
could sit down granted if they still got
along. Um, and these people,
like they had this unbelievable spread
and they had glasses of wine and cheese
and all that. Just giving you the whole
experience because most of the times,
you know, you're traveling, you
don't get to have the experience.
Like I wanted to go to bizarre guitar
and gun shop and I just didn't have the
time to get over there. Um, after I
went over to get the barbecue, um,
you know, when need a bunch of barbecue,
he body just, just like, all right,
shutting down now dealing
with what you just put,
like you just put so much
fucked up shit into your body.
There's not enough energy left to keep
you awake. So your body's just like,
all right, powering down. You know,
it's like when you put
your laptop on sleep mode,
like that's what your body does to
you. Like, yeah, that's why, you know,
black people call it the itis. I know
what white people call it, you know,
whatever the fuck it is. It's like a,
I learned that from Charlie Murphy.
I told this story before,
I got to tell it again.
Charlie Murphy and Darnell Rawlings,
we were on a tour called, uh,
the rich bitch tour.
And that was from when Darnell
Darnell was the guy that did that.
I'm rich bitch that would scream at the
end of the Chappelle show. [inaudible].
So, um, you know, they used to always
just sit there and breaking balls,
breaking balls, breaking balls, you know,
making fun of my clothes and
all that type of shit. And uh,
it was the worst in the morning,
you know what I mean? Cause I've,
I've been wake up,
you know,
hung over or whatever and these
guys will like a couple of kids,
they just woke up like we,
we like they weren't drinking
with me the night before. Um,
I don't say take a multivitamin
is a what? Right. Um,
so one day I was just fucking,
I didn't want to deal with it and we
had this long drive from Chicago all the
way up.
Like Mount Vernon,
I don't even fuck around
Mount Vernon's New York.
I can't remember some way of like a,
it's like a two hour drive.
And I knew that they were going to be
loud and breaking my balls and I went
extra hard and I didn't want to deal
with it. And I was standing out there,
we had this fucking car service, right?
This old ass limo. I remember that.
Are there any new limos by the way?
They're always fucking old as shit. Um,
this old ass fucking literally looked
like the thing was from like the 80s,
this old town car, right. And I'm
standing there going, oh my God,
I don't want to deal with these guys.
They're going to be loud as shit.
And I looked down the street and I
saw a Popeye's and I was just like,
fuck this.
Cause they had taught me about the
itis because Donna was eating so bad.
Darnell was literally buying hot dogs
at the gas stations in Edam and within
fucking five minutes he would be asleep.
Like his body would just power down
dealing with the poison he just put in.
So I went down the street,
went in there and got this giant bucket
of Popeye's chicken with fucking mash
potatoes and biscuits and they
came walking up and I was like,
hey guys, that got us some
food. They don't like, oh all
right man, thanks. Thanks.
And they start eating it and I'm just
sitting there nursing like one drum stick
and they ate that shit in like
within fucking 20 minutes.
They will both passed out and I just
sat with a fucking shitty and grid.
It just wrote in total silence up to
the fucking whatever the fuck we were
going.
So they ago,
if you're ever in a car and you've got
a loud friend or something like that,
a legal way to drug them is you just get
some really bad fast food because it's
poison. It's just all trans fats. Well, I,
I am my own selfish way. I poisoned
two really good friends of mine.
I temporarily poisoned them so I
could just sit there, you know,
and enjoy myself as I wrote up,
you know what I mean?
And is it slightly racist?
Then I went and,
and got a bucket of chicken for two
African Americans in defense of me.
It's the first one that I saw.
It was the first thing that I saw.
I don't fucking know. Anyways,
moving on. What are we up to here?
32 32 in 1951 minutes. Oh,
we're closing in on it there.
Um, oh Jesus Christ. I
haven't, oh Jesus Christ.
I haven't even done the fucking let us
for this week. I'm out. I'm out of it.
I'm out of it here. Where the hell did it
go? Is this them? All right, let's let,
let's let, let's listen to me read out
loud one last time here. Legal Zoom,
everybody. You know, there's
a lot of great reasons.
Smart Business People
Trust legalism for status.
If you want to incorporate form an LLC
or nonprofit file a patent, a trademark,
get a DBA, whatever that is. And more um,
legal zoom provides the help
you need over the past decade,
more than a million business owners, just
like you have started with legal zoom.
But did you know that legal
zoom is also your first stop?
You need advice from an attorney? Oh
yeah. Legal Zone is not a law firm.
So they built a network of independent
attorneys in most states to provide legal
advice and other useful services
to help you run your business.
So whether you need a contract reviewed
or advice on whether you should
incorporate or form an LLC,
whatever your legal question is,
start with legal zoom.com.
And as always,
they provide complete transparency,
transparency with upfront pricing,
customer views,
and 100% satisfaction guarantee.
Make the smart choice for your business
and legal zoom.com today@legalzoom.com
today. And don't forget to enter Burr
at checkout to save even more. Again,
that's [inaudible] at checkout
for more savings, legalzoom,
Promo code bur bur legal help is
here. Oh my God. You know what?
I almost forgot to talk about.
Do you know I watched the end of the
u s open and watch that poor bastard
potting for Eagle.
He's with Wayne Gretzky's daughter.
Wayne Gretzky is in the crowd,
a man who has his name on the cup
four times a man who is a champion.
And you saw Gretzky, had a big smile on
his face like, yeah buddy, here we go,
you sync this fucker,
you go top shelf with this thing.
And it was a long plot and the guy
didn't see, didn't sync it. So it's like,
all right, whatever. And then he had
a three foot plot and I had to leave.
I had to run out to go do my
show and I shut off the TV,
assuming he was going to sink the three
foot plot and then there was going to be
a playoff that I could watch,
you know, before my show,
I guess it would have been today,
they would have played like a whole
nother round of golf for some shit,
I guess is how it works. So I
shut the TV off. Thank God I did.
And as I'm going out I was,
I was going out to, to the,
to the bus.
My phone starts blowing up and people,
some Versie wrote,
Oh my God,
that just made me sick.
And I thought at first
they were talking about,
they were talking about the, uh,
you know him missing the, the,
the Eagle Pot. Right. Um,
I got this message from a buddy of
mine. He wrote, holy fucking Shit.
That's just awful. What does
Gretzky say there? And I wrote back,
did he miss the Birdie Putt too?
And he just wrote Yas like 20
fucking asses. He just lost.
And I wrote, Oh, now he said, miss
the three footer coming back up.
Unreal all time putting choke.
It's shocking.
Did you see? And I wrote, I'm so
glad I missed the second miss.
I ran out to the car
to go over to the show.
I assume you'd hit it and I'd
watched a play off and then I wrote,
golf is fucking devastating
and he will play off at us.
Open is 18 holes on Monday for you
people who are really into golf. Um,
golf has absolutely fucking
emotionally fucking devastating.
I still don't think it's a sport. It's
the most devastating fucking activity.
Like the first masters I ever
sat down and watch wire to wire.
I watch Kenny Perry fall apart.
Yeah,
on 17 and 18 and then go to the playoffs
and fucking loose to the coolest
Argentinian dude. I just, I just,
I can't get over
how fucking devastating I eat.
What kills me is this is to think
it's just a complete mind. Fuck.
It's the biggest mind fuck out there.
I believe in that kid though,
even though he missed those two things.
I believe that kids a stud,
he's going to come back and uh,
I feel bad that everyone's going to say
he's a big fucking choker and all that,
like they've ever dealt with
any sort of pressure like that.
So whatever his fucking name is,
I'm not into golf.
Um, I got MP three, four
year, I believe in you.
You're going to be back and uh,
it's only gonna make you stronger.
And they're just the fact that he could
actually just not break down into tears
right there on national television.
He probably did later on that night.
And there's nothing wrong with that.
I would have just, when I missed it,
I would've just let,
not even like through my club doubt,
I would've just let go of it.
You know? That's even worse.
That's when you're devastated.
When you can't even make your muscles
work anymore. You're like, you're so sad.
You can't even, you can't even hold
anything. You just let go. Whoa.
It'd be fucking hilarious.
And you don't even finish your pot.
You just fucking kick it with your
foot. I don't give a fuck. He is.
You have to be carried off.
Like you remember when James Brown
would do that thing and they'd bring the
fucking coat over two of them.
Like they have to do that except it's a
little golf Poncho and the golf umbrella
and they're just bringing you in as
somebody patting you on the chest.
Come on bill. Come on. I would have done
that. So just the fact that he could,
he had to walk out in front of all of
those people with their heads high and you
know,
they were all looking at him.
Okay.
In some way.
A lot of them will love in it because
they never made it to a u s open. So,
uh, I don't know, just the fact
that he was fucking in there first,
he actually wrote that was so devastating.
The guy who won didn't even
enjoy it. Oh my God. It was,
it's one of the most brutal
fucking things, you know,
it was right up there with watching the
Seahawks throw the ball and have it get
intercepted.
But at least then like
the devastation of that,
it's spread across 40 men.
You know what I mean?
Who can be all devastated
together as opposed to golf?
It's just you by yourself.
There's no defense trying to pick the
ball off or guess what you're doing,
jumping around.
It's just you in three feet of grass.
Another my,
one of my buddies was shitting on the
fucking what the golf course look like.
He goes, dude, that golf
course looks like my backyard.
I hated it at first,
but after a while I kind of liked it.
I thought it was kind of a bad
ass course man. It looked like a,
they stopped in the middle of a war and
decided to play 18 holes cause they had
like the gallery.
Then we're in like these look like these
ruins these buildings or some shit that
had been torn up. Anyway, so let's get
to the questions here for the week.
A bill where all the John Wayne,
this is from a lady. Uh, hello bill.
I'm a big fan.
I hope this gets to you.
Me and my husband take the drive from
Austin to Houston visiting his dad in the
hospital quite often.
Uh Oh man. That's sad.
I hope it gets better or I don't know.
I hope there's something in then its
benefit. I just made me sad. Anyways,
the drive can can feel long, but we cut
in. Cut It in half with your podcast. Oh,
there we go. We get good laughs and
we don't have to talk to each other.
I'm writing to get your opinion.
I may be wrong,
but I'm open to hear what you think. I
wanted to have a pedicure on my birthday.
I dragged my husband with me.
It's,
it is the best place to get a foot and
calf massage. He's never had a pedicure,
so I wanted for him to
experience it with me.
He was not a fan. He didn't feel like
his feet were being touched by another,
what? He didn't like. His feet
being touched by another man.
Ah, ah. Oh God.
Another man giving you a calf massage.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
When is this month today and my God,
the uncomfortableness of this
month. Jesus Christ. Yeah.
He thinks women try to emasculate
men by having them get wax,
spray Tan and have pedicures.
He's always referenced in
men in Hollywood by saying,
where are all the John Waynes?
I wasn't trying to emasculate him,
but to give them a new experience
and hope that he would enjoy a little
relaxation.
He wasn't into it.
Tell me if you get pedicures and if
you would enjoy them, you're great.
Go Fuck Yourself. Uh, no, I don't
get pedicures. This is the thing.
Men are not allowed to enjoy any sensual
experience unless it's with the female.
Like women can just sit there and let
another woman touched their feet and
massage there cast and be like, oh my
God, that feels so good. Thank you Stacy.
You know,
we're not allowed to this.
The thing about it is his guys were like,
what I pictured guys remember,
remember those old
square TVs that you had?
That's like what a guy is physically
with just like these blocks, you know,
and we'll just like,
what?
Not like that I'm getting grossed out.
This is just gross and maybe I'm fucking
immature. But now you know something
I think,
I dunno, maybe I'm wrong. Uh, the song
we need, cause she'll fucking soft.
And what I'm going to say here. What
the fuck are you doing to your man here?
Why don't you want that guy?
You see fucking read the second.
Anybody in intruder comes in.
You killing that off of him.
The EAG. He's just going to grab some
fucking lamp and start smashing it over.
Somebody who's fucking head.
If they come to your house,
if he keeps getting a calf massage
and getting his toes fucking painting.
What do you,
what are you doing to you?
You're rehabbing a pit bull here for no
fucking reason. He's fine the way it is.
Oh my God. No. You know
something. I think I did one time.
I did get a pedicure. I get when I
was on the fucking rich bitch tour.
He knows something. Black
Dudes, we'll get manicures.
They'll get manicures. I think it was
a manicure. Did I have, you know, I,
I know I got a pedicure one time.
I think I was with Nia.
I think I blocked it up. Yeah,
I think we were in New York.
I got a pedicure and then the lady was
rubbing my calves and all it did was make
me want to get a fucking, you know what?
Happy ending. It was just like, yeah,
keep going, keep going. Skip the size,
get to the finish line.
Um,
I,
I dunno.
Okay.
I don't really even
remember the experience.
I just remember I did it because
she asked me to do it and I did it.
And I remember laughing.
I remember being really immature and when
I dip my feet into the fucking water,
it just was making me laugh.
I was like,
I almost lost control of myself because
it was just something that was so
fucking foreign to me.
Um,
and I was sitting and
then the more I laughed,
the more near was laughing and she just
kept laughing, going, what? It's nice.
It's nice. And I just kept laughing
going, what are you doing to me?
Um, and then afterwards, I don't
know, but I will say afterwards,
my toes, nails where's clean as they've
ever fucking bed. But, uh, you know, I'll,
you know, I'll just get one of those
fucking 50 cent scrub brushes. Uh,
I'll just say, can you leave him
alone? You know what I mean? You,
you can, I understand you trying to
like give them a nice experience,
but like that can go a little too far.
And next thing you know,
you, you're wondering what happened to
the man you married or maybe you're not,
maybe you're more evolved. I don't
know. Maybe women are more involved.
I don't fucking know. Don't ask me
those questions. I feel gross right now.
All right.
Please explain this to me.
Caitlin Jenner is receiving an
award at the espys for her courage,
which is apparently the
greatest thing ever.
What they don't tell you is the person
who won't be receiving the award now is
Lauren Hill,
the girl who was diagnosed,
diagnosed with inoperable brain cancer.
Oh, Lauren Hill does to singer.
She played her first game. Oh,
so this is a,
it has the same thing.
She played her first game for her college
basketball game after a diagnosis.
I saw this,
I saw this fucking story
and for months to come,
she raised over a million
dollars for cancer research.
She died a couple of months later.
So please explain to me why a guide
shopping his dick off is more courageous
than standing up to cancer. You know,
I'll tell you why. Because you know what,
at the end of the day, it's
show business. That's why,
okay,
it's fucking show business.
Um,
I know somebody that writes on that show
and I know of something that happened
that I'm can't say,
and someone was in the truck flipping
out that it was going on too long.
And all they were thinking about was,
you know,
going like just the worst fucking moment
in my life because this person up there,
I'm, I'm going to say what it was, but
it's just, it's fucking show business.
That's why. So they're probably
going like, oh, do we want
to bring the room down?
Or maybe like,
well,
but they always have something about
somebody dying on that show, the,
the touching moment, you know what
I mean? But then they're thinking,
oh Caitlyn Jenner is really hot right now.
It has the high Q rating or something
like that. That'll give us more.
MMM.
I don't know why. Why, why, why? I
don't understand what that award is.
I can see if Katelyn just went
out on one another, the castle on
like they kind of given basically the
giving it to Bruce Jenner in a way.
The way they gave fucking a Martin
Scorsese, the Oscar for the departed,
cause they fucked up on a raging bull.
They didn't give it to him for
fucking Goodfellas. They audit tool.
So I think they owed Bruce Jenner of
fucking sp. They never gave it to him.
It's like fuck, we waited too
long. Cause now Bruce is Katelyn.
Well maybe we can give it to her and
she can give it to him through a brain.
I don't fucking know.
I don't produce shows.
And by that last fucking horrific answer,
you can understand why. All right.
The age of technology,
dare Billy bombsight.
I'm an open miker in a semi small city
and don't really expect to get much
attention in this place.
Well that's a great place to start.
Don't videotape yourself and get better.
Well,
videotape yourself the don't upload it
onto youtube and get used to get real
good. Then move to a better city with
more exposure and then become a monster.
Anyways.
Um,
I recently found out that someone at
an open mic was recording video of
everyone's set off.
Fuck it.
Put all the capture content onto their
social network page, including mine.
When I found out that my
shitty undeveloped open
miking was on the Internet,
I was furious as you should have been
contacted. The individual that posted it,
they have since taken
most of the content down,
but I had a long argument about this
situation with a different person.
They argued in defense of this lady by
saying, this is the world we live in now.
You were in a public place and that
gave her the right to record you.
The worst that happens is that you say
something stupid and get and you get
publicity for it. Any publicity is good
publicity. All right? You know what?
That person's going to be a
fucking hack. Um, he said,
my argument is basically that if
she earns any money from my content,
then I have a right to be pissed off.
I also feel very uneasy thinking about
the possibility of saying something
stupid about a current event and getting
flak on Twitter just because I thought
it was funny and no one else did.
Yeah.
And you're also brand new to comedy and
you should be allowed to make mistakes,
uh,
with the recent popularity of the APP
periscope and hearing you bitch a little
bit about it. I would like to hear
your opinion on this argument. Thanks.
And Go shag yourself.
A PSU still have fans in Nebraska.
Um, yeah, no, I'm a hundred
percent agreement with you.
You should be allowed to
develop as an open micro,
but you can't get mad at the lady.
Like they don't understand that what
they're doing could be detrimental. Um,
and it is the world that we
live in because people do
do that. But you're, you,
you are right.
Um,
and I don't understand why everybody
feels like they have to videotape every
fucking moment of their
lives. Now. It's all like,
it's almost like they're
campaigning for this office of, Hey,
I have the coolest life. Like
always taken a selfie. Like,
you know, this is me and
old faithful. You know,
it's so what I was supposed
to look at it like, wow,
this guy is fucking goes everywhere.
You know what I mean? I, I don't,
I don't understand it. I mean, I
guess I do that though and I do that.
I took a picture of me and, uh, well it
wasn't a Selfie, but me and Bart, nick,
when we were in Reno
with that iconic sign,
I don't know, but I wish people
wouldn't do it at live events. Um,
especially when there's jokes because
the new jokes become old jokes. But, um,
I think that's going to end because
they're now coming out with these,
as these businesses popping up for
entertainers where they're going to block
people's cell phones during
the performance, which is, uh,
just pretty awesome.
I think if it's like up to the artists,
although I'm also guilty cause I watch
all this shit that people videotape the
Stevie Ray Vaughan and that type of thing.
Um,
and then you get to enjoy the
performance. But, you know,
I don't think I'm going out on a limb to
say that you're not at your Stevie ray
Vaughan level of being a standup yet.
It'd be nice if he could
be allowed to develop. Um,
people have recorded my shows and
whenever I reach out to him on Youtube,
they always take them down.
I never get mad at him.
I understand that they're not in the
business and they don't get what that what
they're doing actually
hurts me on some level. Um,
so just deal with it. Whatever.
Fuck that dude who, Jay,
this is the world we live in.
You know those people who don't get mad
that the government can record all your
phone conversations? It just
like, well, hey, you know,
if you're not doing anything wrong,
what's the problem? Those fucking people.
Anyways,
I gotta I gotta wrap this up here cause
I gotta be on the bus in 10 minutes. Uh,
roommates lady wants to move in
a, hey Billy Bob, ginger tits,
Jesus Christ, enough with the red head
jokes. Can you guys go with something new?
It's getting fucking boring here.
Um,
my roommate of five years has
this new lady who is cool,
but off the bad seems
kind of manipulative.
He told me that she's getting kicked out
of her place and she wants to move into
our two bedroom apartment in New
York City, which isn't that big.
As you would know for three months,
she wants to move there for three months.
The rest would be split three ways.
They're planning on moving in together
after she stays for three months.
Do I accept the cheaper rent or
tell her to take a hike? By the way,
they'd been dating for six months.
You rule. Go Fuck Yourself. Now.
That manipulative con is going to
end up convincing her boy, boyfriend.
You're going to be the guy who's going to
leave because she's not going to leave.
They're going to ask you to leave and
you're like, fuck you, I'm not leaving,
and then it's going to be
two against one and your,
your life's going to be miserable.
Do not on any level allow her to move in.
Say this is a two bedroom apartment.
This is for two people, not for three.
It affects my quality of life.
There's not enough money in the fucking
universe for me to compromise my,
um, my quality of life. So no, that's it.
No. And you stand by
that and fuck him. Okay.
And fuck her. And then that's it. And you
won't have to deal with that situation.
And with any luck,
he'll fucking move out and you'll get
another roommate and you won't be involved
in that situation.
Then you'll have more power because then
you'll have been there longer than the
other person. All right? That is
one of the easiest questions ever.
Do not on any level.
Let her move in six months in,
you're codependent fucking pussy.
He'll fuck yourself.
Oh my God.
And then now you got to wait.
You're gonna have to wait 10 times
longer to go into the bathroom.
Cause not only do you
have another roommate,
it's a woman and they
take for fucking ever,
cause he can fucking go to put on all
that clown makeup and shit. All right,
I'm done. Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.